Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen lieben Morgen Tim.
Schon alles gesagt zum zweiunddreißig C drei oder fällt dir noch irgendwas ein?
Wir könnten noch so über die äh EU Datenschutzreform sprechen, die waren nicht im Programm.
Logbuch äh Netzpolitik hundertsiebenundsechzig in schneller Folge. Nachdem wir uns äh letztes Mal so ausführlich über den zweiunddreißig C3 ausgekäst haben.
Schieben wir gleich nochmal was hinterher.
Weil sich das so ergeben hat, weil wir irgendwie nicht genug kriegen können. Den Hals nicht vollkriegen können. Also machen wir ein kleines Spezial ähm sozusagen als Nachtrag über, wie schon erwähnt, ein Thema, was auf dem Kongress äh gar nicht so die Rolle gespielt hat.
Nämlich die EU-Datenschutzverordnung.
Ja und ähm da können wir eigentlich auch gleich voranschreiten. Wir haben nämlich äh heute einen Gast und zwar Professor Doktor Nikolaus Forgo. Schönen guten Tag.
Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Frau Go spricht man das aus, ja? Mit so einem schmissigen Ohr am Ende.
Okay, wieder was gelernt. Ja, sie sind äh Professor äh für Rechtsinformatik und IT-Recht. Äh an der Leibniz-Universität in Hannover.
Ähm seit wann?
Also schon eine ganze Weile.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Rechtsinformatik und IT Recht.
Womit beschäftigt man sich da so im Wesentlichen?
Also insofern ist dann die äh EU-Datenschutzverordnung, die jetzt verabschiedet wurde oder verabschiedet werden wird, ich weiß gar nicht, ist der letzte Schritt jetzt eigentlich schon gemacht, äh das steht auf jeden Fall so in ihrem Fokus auch.
Sie haben das auch äh begleitet über die gesamte Zeit.
Hm. Aber sie haben das quasi so von Anfang an verfolgt auf den äh auf den ersten Metern. Was was war denn so da ihre erste Erwartungshaltung?
Äh Fortschreibung, welches Status quo ist, ist das jetzt so die spezifisch deutsche äh Sicht oder.
Gemeinsame Nenner.
Also hat sich gar nicht so viel geändert.
Was bedeutet das denn für so eine also könnte man denn diesen Begriff trennscharf formulieren? Also gäbe es da Vorschläge.
Hm
Jetzt wurde ja über über lange Zeit.
Viel nachgedacht. Ähm darüber, wo, äh, das, worüber nachgedacht wurde, haben wir aber allenfalls immer durch irgendwelche Leaks erfahren.
Sie haben da auch in ihrem Artikel auf Heise einiges drüber geschrieben. Wie würden sie sich denn so einen Prozess eigentlich vorstellen?
Genau das ist ja der Punkt. Was wurde denn jetzt beschlossen? Also das der letzte.
Diese letzte Einigung, von der wir jetzt überhaupt sprechen, ist ja keine,
offizielle, oder? Das ist einfach nur erstmal der Abschluss des Trilogs. Das ist jetzt noch kein Dokument, das in seiner Form jetzt schon rechtlich bindend wäre, oder?
Es ist ja am Ende auch eine Frage der Umsetzung. Die Richtlinie gibt ja letzten Endes nur
den Rahmen vor für äh konkrete nationale Regelungen. Inwiefern kann denn jetzt davon ausgegangen werden, dass auf Basis dieser Richtlinie,
dieses eigentliche Ziel, was ja hier äh auch allseits bejubelt wurde, einer Vereinheitlichung der Datenschutzstandards in den einzelnen Ländern auch.
Dann nach sich zieht.
Können sie das mal so ein bisschen konkretisieren, was sie da so an, an, an Unterschieden in der Auslegung äh erwarten? Also gibt's da vielleicht irgend so ein Beispiel, wo sich das so konkret ähm abzeichnet?
Was gibt's da konkret zum Beispiel für Pole? Also wenn man jetzt mal das das Beispiel mal herausgreift, würden die da so zwei Länder fallen, die so an den äh entgegengesetzten Enden äh liegen.
Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass der Süden und der Osten jetzt besonders datenschutz ähm rigide wäre, oder?
Verstehe, die sind einfach noch nicht so weit. Ähm.
Wie bewerten sie denn jetzt den konkreten.
Ablauf ähm die Datenschutzverordnung war ja im Prinzip des
das umkämpfteste Rechtsprojekt eigentlich der letzten Jahre, wenn man sich nur die Zahl der äh Änderungsanträge anschaut
Ähm es gab ja also eine ungeheure äh Lobby-Aktivität, die ja dann auch zu so,
geführt hat wie Lobbywatch und so, dann eigens noch Software äh entwickelt wurde, um sozusagen diesen ganzen Änderungswald überhaupt noch zu überblicken.
Warum gerade hier und was hat das für eine Auswirkung gehabt auf diesen ganzen Prozess?
Also ist das dein überflüssig? Kann man das jetzt so auslegen, muss ich sagen?
Und genau da wäre doch jetzt eigentlich der Punkt gewesen, wo man ein.
Wo man dem Ziel eines Datenschutzrechts für das einundzwanzigste und wahrscheinlich sogar zweiundzwanzigste Jahrhundert ähm und auf der anderen Seite einer Vereinheitlichung innerhalb der EU.
Hätte näher kommen können. Und da sagen sie das, das ist in der Form in keiner Form. Das ist.
Aber betet die Verordnung jetzt vielleicht, zumindest eine stabile Diskussionsbasis, um jetzt die nächsten Schritte anzugehen. Ich meine, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht dann schon mal äh äh vielleicht gut, dass man.
So eine Fest, also selbst wenn's der Status quo ist, aber er ist halt sozusagen festgeschrieben, was was werden denn so jetzt die nächsten
Bedarf. Also sie meinen ja in dem Text gefühlt ist das Ding jetzt schon siebzig Jahre alt, weil man irgendwie zehn Jahre drüber diskutiert hat und das Internet alles mal sieben nimmt. Ähm was was sind denn so die nächsten
dringenden Fragen, die im Prinzip auch auf EU-Regende Ebene geregelt werden sollten, aber jetzt noch nicht sind.
Ja, aber gut, das äh beantwortet nicht so ganz meine Frage nach etwas so äh also was sind sozusagen jetzt was wären jetzt konkrete Themenfelder oder Fragestellungen, die jetzt in dem Sinne noch nicht abgehandelt sind, die jetzt die nächsten Debatten bestimmen sollen.
Also wir würden gerne wegkommen von diesem äh einmal äh EU-ler anklicken und dann äh ist alles so, wie Facebook das gemacht hat, hinzu so ein bisschen Datenschutz la carte, dass man nicht nur Privatsphäre Einstellungen äh.
So ein bisschen rumkonfigurieren kann, sondern damit auch quasi die rechtliche Bindung äh damit verkoppelt.
Subjekt Twinterpretation, das ist eigentlich das, was wir weghaben wollten und dass wir jetzt für die nächsten Jahre weiter haben werden.
Ähm sie hat noch äh in dem Text noch äh
bisschen über die künftige Rolle für die Datenschützer ähm die betrieblichen Datenschützer konkret äh gesprochen. Ähm
Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden, was für Auswirkungen sehen sie denn dort?
Aber könnte anderes rum auch äh bedeuten, dass Irland auch weiterhin sehr äh facebookfreundlich auftreten kann, indem sie äh einfach sagen, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Ja ich sag mal äh vielen Dank für ähm diesen Blick.
Das hören wir natürlich gerne.
Die Freude ist ganz auf unserer Seite.
Okay, alles, alles.
Tschüss. Ja, die Nost, dem ist nicht viel hinzuzufügen, oder?
Nee, dem ist nicht viel hinzuzufügen und ich freue mich, dass wir auch mal ähm einen einen kompetenten Gelehrten in dieser Sendung.
Aber halten wir doch schon auf den Kongress.
Ah ja, scheiße, stimmt, das kann man so nicht.
Aber vielleicht äh finden wir ja noch andere ähm andere Schätze in unserer Hörerschaft, nennt sich das schon äh so gut entwickelt.
Genau, wenn wir unsere Hörer dann plötzlich auf Heise lesen, dann haben sie auch eine Chance. Carsten wir sofort weg.
Schlagen wir zu. Können wir nix. Okay, das war's. Kurze Sache heute im Vergleich, aber ist ja auch mal schön. Letztes Mal war ja schon so lang. Okay, bis tschüss.
Bis tschüss.
Ist, tschüss.
Tschüss, servus. Bis wiedersehen.